aux pommes sur la terre cependant je
suis content de voir mes petits enfants
ont le seul et hop tu veux autres aux
grands soirs les enfants notre nounours
et bien gai si nous lui faisions une
blague
nous allons lui accrocher un ballon dans
le dos et nounours revient aux excuses
l'on tourne le dos n'as tu as quelque
chose de sale je te l'enlève bercy a
trop vous êtes trop beau voilà ce
n'était rien une poussière l'a pas tout
de suite
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
on va bien s'amuser les enfants ça lui
laisse aux chicanes tu nous apporter un
ballon non ni kobin pas si tu nous
apporta pas les problèmes
on va te montre à cheetah ballon la
décision à la noce est un regard oui
regard est pas vrai les gars là
[Rires]
regarde regarde dans la glace
voyons mais oui j'ai un palau il me suit
au le voilà encore aux mains c'est
formidable
allons les petits au lit je vais montrer
ce phénomène au marchand de sable
or les mystères de la nature
c'est unique ce qui m'arrive
bonne nuit non ce petit belle en reste
bien avec nous nos ce bonne nuit les
hauts-fonds la chute en quelques petites
annonces là je tends la lumière
demain tenus nicolas bonnieu grenelle
corbières mais oui c'est notre nounours
qui remonte déjà pas trop pas trop l
aventure c'est extraordinaire qu'y a
t'il d'extraordinaire mon bon nounours
jeu un ballon qui me suit partout où je
à
mais c'est vrai approche toi un peu que
je te l'enlève
la voilà gros nigo je ne comprends plus
potro c'est moi qui l'avait attachée
gros bêta je t'ai fait une blague au
poteau ceux de port sur nous mais je
t'ai bien attraper bonne nuit des
enfants allez vite vous coucher le
faible cours
[Musique]
vous
oh
[Musique]